this huge hole is in the side of what  appears to be a medical facility you can  see stretches you can see discards of  medicine lots of medical equipment we  know that this town has been fought over  pretty fiercely by both sides  particularly over the past few days and  that the Russians held it for many  months it's impossible to determine at  this early stage just which side was  responsible for inflicting all this  damage if you look through some of the  windows I can see baby's cots and this  section at least appears to be a  maternity unit now both sides know that  it is against international law to  attack a medical facility like this one  and it is surely going to be the subject  of a long investigation to determine  which side wrought such destruction on  this medical facility because it does  constitute an international War crime